A point is a position and a vector describes a motion. We can combine points and
vectors in various useful ways by adding or subtracting their coordinates from
one another. To start with, if you subtract the location of point A from point
B, you get a vector describing how to get from point A to point B. So B minus A
is calculated by taking the coordinates and subtracting them from one another.
And this gives you vector v. The reverse also holds true. A plus v equals B.
While we can subtract points to get in a vector. Our system doesn't produce
anything geometrically meaningful if you add the 2 points together. We can also
add and subtract vectors themselves. For example, S plus T equals U. We can also
reverse this process. For example, U minus T equals S. And we can go the other
way around. For example, U minus S equals T. One way to think about vector
subtraction is that you're, instead, adding a vector going the opposite
direction, as shown here. The other thing commonly done with vectors and points
is to multiply them by a scalar, that is, a number. Multiplying a vector by a
scalar is clear enough. You want to describe moving further in a given
direction. If you multiply by negative 1, you reverse the vector's direction.
Multiply by a different negative number and you'll reverse the direction and
change how far to move. Multiplying the point by a number is way to make an
object look larger or smaller. This type if operations called scaling, we'll
discuss in detail later.